now in terms of all of the vectors that
I've just got here a negative A and P
how would I um how would I get to
um uh not oh yeah how would I get from a
to P which vectors would I string
together have a think about it
um
I go I want to get to P but the way I
would do it is via M wouldn't it right
so like you said I've gone in the
opposite direction to a which like you
said is negative a and then you just add
on P right so let's write that we do the
opposite direction a and then we add on
paid fantastic okay
now the next one I've got is from B to p
and that's actually very easy to do
because I already know the right
direction to go in right if I start from
here I'm going to go towards M which is
what vector
uh a yeah it's negative of negative a
right which is just a
and then I add on P now the reason why I
care about AP and BP let's just sort of
highlight those
um here's AP which I'm going to put in
Orange and then um let's do BP up here
in green what's the relationship between
AP and BP again
they're actually like what I started
with was what's given is that there
there's 90 degrees there yeah
yeah so I would say hey
um AP and BP are right angled to each
other now think think this part's hard
and I'm not going to tell you I'm going
to ask you to do it right thinking
vectors what is the special thing that
you know if two vectors are orthogonal
to each other what's the knowledge here
you've got to call back a couple of
weeks actually yeah yeah okay
um there's a particular operation that
we can do with two vectors what is it
yeah yeah it's the product hold on
product rule is something we think of
from calculus there's a particular kind
of product we introduced
what's the notation it's a
it's a DOT right so it's it's the dot
product so what we know very good by the
way you got there and there was no one
else in the class so you really had to
lift right is that when two vectors are
at right angles when they're orthogonal
or perpendicular then when you take
their dot product you get a DOT product
of what again
of one oh hold on hold on it's zero it's
zero because the dot product if you
think back the dot product is how are
these vectors working together with each
other right if they're like pushing
against each other you get a negative
dot product if they're going in the same
direction you get a positive dot product
but when they're perpendicular they're
not working with or against each other
they're just kind of like off in random
you know independent directions so
that's why it's zero okay
now here's the thing I actually know
what AP and BP are we just stated them
up above so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to write uh what's ap well it's um
it's I'll write it in an easier order
it's p takeaway a do you agree with that
yeah and then what was the BP Vector
again
yeah very good p plus a so I've got
those when you do the dot product
between them you get zero okay
now at this point here I don't know
about you I looked at this and I was
like oh what do I what do I do with this
now I'm not going to work it all through
I'm going to show it to you very quickly
but I'm not going to write it out and
I'm not going to ask you to write it out
because very laborious but you can look
back at the recording if you're curious
about this right one of the reasons why
we call the dot product like a product
just like normal multiplication is that
just like in numbers the dot product is
what we call distributive now that's a
really weird word but all it means is
when you when you've got something like
a binomial like this right if I gave you
um you know uh sorry let me choose
better
um letters X Plus One X plus three right
if I gave you that as a product you know
you can distribute the X to the terms on
the other side
and then you would distribute the one to
the terms on the other side right like
you've done this like literally
thousands of times right now the same is
actually true in the dot product right
what you will get is I can distribute P
to everything in the second pair of
brackets so let's actually write this
now down now I could go P dot p
and then when you distribute it again
it's um it's p dot a do you agree with
that yep and then can you help me
distribute the next one what am I going
to get here uh P dot negative a yep I'll
just write it as a minus out the front
so yep a DOT p and then what's the last
one
um uh minus a DOT a very good
now just this is the part that I'm not
going to ask you to write down but I'm
just going to quickly
um I'll put an asterisk here I'm just
going to quickly show you that this this
is actually true because it feels a bit
rabbit out of a hat you're like do I
believe that I don't know we hardly do
this kind of thing so I've um here's
what I prepared earlier and you'll see
why I'm not getting you to write it down
this is the distributive property of the
dot product it's not hard it's just a
lot of writing so you can see I'm I'm
imagining these three-dimensional
vectors here
um we'll keep going if that's okay I
know that was a bell and if I if I
imagine just let's do the arithmetic
right it just ends up this is me doing
the dot product and this is
um you know the x is multiplied by each
other here are the Y's multiplied by
each other and here are the Z's
multiplied by each other does that make
sense
now I know this looks weird I've written
this out in four lines just to make
something very obvious right so can you
see I've gone a times L A times o That's
these two lines then I've gone D times l
d times o so that's these two lines I've
done it in four lines because when you
have a look just look at this blue line
the top one here right
this is X's multiplied by X's Y is
multiplied by y's and Z is multiplied by
Zeds do you see that
so it's a DOT product between ABC
and LMN and it just goes like each of
the rows blue pink green and orange is
just a new DOT product but when you
combine them together what you get is
the distributive property right now like
I said I don't expect you to
um look at this now and say like oh of
course right this took me a long time to
sort of write and think out but I just
want you to not just believe me like hey
the dot product works like this I want
you to know it can be proven and it's
quite easy it just is a lot of writing
is that okay
yeah yeah all right so let's come back
to here and let's actually finish this
out because this is this is the fun part
okay so pick up your pen again have a
look on the left hand side here there's
some things that just cancel right what
what cancels yeah
very good because the dot product is not
just distributive it's also commutative
because it's just multiplication right
so these terms here they just cancel
right yep so what I end up with is on
the left hand side I have P dot p
and then if I add that minus Vector
there right that negative Vector I've
got a DOT a
on the right hand side
okay now this part is so so strange do
you remember what happens when you do a
vector and you dot product against
itself do you remember that
oh lucky fight let's actually write this
out um if I've got a vector and I dot
product against itself what do you get
like just multiply across all the terms
of squared that's right all the terms
are squared now what this really is is
just this is the square of the magnitude
do you recognize that like if I took the
magnitude there's Pythagoras and then
I've just squared it
so what I've got yeah very good what
I've got is the magnitude of P
but squared that's the same as the
magnitude of a but squared right
um but hold on these are all squared
these are really just distances right so
I can just say the magnitude of p is the
same as the magnitude of a
yeah
yeah now go back to our diagram let me
zoom out let's have a look at our
diagram where are p and a have a look
here right yeah what you've just told me
what we've just proved is the magnitude
of p is the same as the magnitude of a
but but the magnitude of a is the same
as the magnitude of negative a
over here do you see that yeah so what
we're saying is hey look A and B
and P yeah do you see it yes it's like
oh
they're all points on the circumference
but there's this one magical point in
the middle of the circle that's the same
distance from these three points on the
circumference there's only one point in
the middle of the circle that does that
what point is that
it's the center of the circle so I can
say
um therefore m p equals m a which equals
m b i e m is the center of the circle
and that's the same really as saying but
a b is the diameter I I don't even need
to really say that because it's it's
it's sort of done right
and and so what we've done is like we've
pulled the dot product out which is a
very unexpected thing and use some of
our our Vector arithmetic and Vector
thinking to construct this proof
um on my channel I've got some videos
that prove this with you know deductive
geometry I've got ones appear with
coordinate geometry but I actually think
this Vector proof is one of my favorites
because it uses um some really clever
thinking and results and you saw it you
had the oh I get it now right
um that moment is really satisfying